well Queen Elizabeth became Monarch five
years after India's independence she
made three state visits to the country
during her Reign let's find out how her
death has been received there Neville
Lazarus is in Delhi for us this morning
uh we'll understand there is a a day of
vigil Neville
that's correct Anna though it has been
quite muted out here the government has
ordered for a day of mourning where the
national flag will fly half Mars and
there will be no uh government official
ceremony at all in in the country now
the queen has made three trips to India
1961
1983 and 1997 all accompanied with a
life partner Prince Philip she she
she literally went down this this this
road down to the president's house which
is behind me where she was she would uh
she would have been given the state
ceremonial uh welcome out there and as
you mentioned she was just five uh five
years after Indie gained its
independence in 1947 from Britain and
has known all the leaders right from
Mahatma Gandhi to the present-day prime
minister uh narender Modi who's met her
twice
but after 75 years of Independence this
is New India this is a very confident uh
assertive and buoyant and a very young
India more than half of India's
population is under the age of 25 and
they are disconnected with bygone areas
of uh kingship and kings and queens and
now they are confident to be at to be
dealt with at par they want Equitable
and just this week itself India overtook
Britain as the as the fifth largest
economy in the world so
it will be quite a lot for the new
monarch who has been here 10 times in
the past to forge and strengthen these
relations with not only the largest
democracy in the world but more
importantly the largest Commonwealth
country with a population of 1.3 billion
people